hi there today we're looking at
regularizing trajectory optimization
with denoising auto-encoders by Renu
boney Normandy Paulo and others of
various places but a lot of the people
are from curious AI and we actually had
a discussion with Hari who is the CEO of
curious AI and this was on our machine
learning Street Talk podcast so this is
another YouTube channel for those of you
who don't know where every week or so we
try to have either an interesting
discussion or a guest like sort of an
interview or talk about comment on the
talk so if it is not out yet a link to
it as soon as it comes out but if you're
watching this video later make sure to
check out our conversation with Hari
because it was absolutely fantastic and
in general if you like videos like this
consider subscribing liking sharing if
you're still here at the end and liked
it ok so this paper on a high level
deals with model-based reinforcement
learning model-based reinforcement
learning means that you are using a
model of the world to do reinforcement
learning so in essence if you have the
reinforcement learning setup where you
are an agent and you have to interact
with the world you have to do so in many
steps in like a round-trip fashion so
you put an action you act and the world
gives you back an observation and you
have to act in the world over and over
and over such that you will be able to
maximize your reward now what is
model-based reinforcement learning
basically means that the agent here has
internally a model of the world so it
sort of understands how the world works
situations where you have a accurate
model of the world are things like chess
so in chess the rules are very clear you
know how the world is going to behave if
you perform a certain action but in real
world applications it's very very hard
to actually make mo
so people usually rely on learned models
so what does it mean you basically learn
a neural network that tries to predict
how the world is going to act so this
here is going to be a deep neural
network that you learn from what you see
in the world now
trajectory optimization basically means
that you are now you now have this world
model and you use it to look ahead as I
said so you are in the state like Hyrum
you can do let's say three different
actions and you use your world model
here world and you see you you think
how's the world going to react if I do
either of those three things and then
you get into three different states and
then again you after each one you
consider three actions three actions
here three actions here and so on so
ultimately you're going to kind of have
an overview over a planning horizon
which here what we call H you kind of
look ahead a couple of steps or there
are various ways of doing this but
ultimately you will basically find that
ah this this path here is really good so
I think I'm going to take this as a
first action so trajectory optimization
considers finding the best green path
here in this tree of possibilities that
your world model gives you okay now what
is what do these people say they say
this procedure often suffers from
exploiting inaccuracies of the learned
model what does that mean that basically
means that if I have a world model and
it is not accurate then it is basically
basically the the thing that tries to
find the best green path here the
optimizer is sort of trying to find the
the best path against this world model
now if that world model is inaccurate
that can lead to devastating
consequences so what do we mean by this
I'll give you an example if you have a
room right and the room is let's take
our classic room like this
and you are here and you would like to
go here and so you're a reinforcement
learning agent did you do some
exploration right you explore a bit here
the next episode you might go here and
you might go here and so on and overtime
in this framework you're gonna build a
model of the world so at the beginning
we won't tell you how these rooms look
you have to discover it by yourself so
maybe at the beginning we only tell you
there's these four walls the rest you
have to figure out so on and on you're
gonna fill in your blanks you do your
first explorations and you say ha
there's a bit of a wall here right and
there might be some wall here I crashed
into that right you're going to hear the
crash into a wall you say ah there's a
wall here and here are there's a wall
here you go maybe here oh there's no
wall so you go further there's no wall
anywhere here you crash here okay we
already knew there's a wall maybe you
crash here alright so right now you have
okay you go here you have you have a
model of the world in this situation
where there's a wall here wall down and
if you now try to do trajectory
optimization remember you have to go
from here to here if you try to do
trajectory optimization what is it going
to turn out it's going to turn out like
look there you go that works just fine
and that's big not because you're so
good at planning
I mean you are good at planning but
because your model is inaccurate here
because it has never seen this your
entire training distribution that you
trained the world model on only explored
the area over here right so you see how
the more efficient this planning
algorithm is like the blue arrow that
the thing that finds the blue arrow the
more efficient that is the more
consequential it is when you're a
learned world model has mistakes because
it will exactly exploit these mistakes
in order to get the shortest path
possible or the highest reward in that
case and this take they call this like
almost an adversarial attack on the
world model which is a pretty good way
of framing it
they propose actually to solve this
problem they say we propose to
regularize trajectory optimization by
means of a denoising auto-encoder that
is trained on the same trajectories as
the model of the environment we show
that the proposed regularization leads
to improved planning with both gradient
based and gradient free optimizers we
also demonstrate that using regularize
trajectory optimization leads to rapid
initial learning in a set of popular
motor control tasks which suggests that
the proposed approach can be useful tool
for improving sample efficiency so in
essence what do they do they basically
say okay we want to regularize this
using a denoising auto-encoder and i
think it's best if we if we look at the
at the math for doing this so the math
here starts off as follows saying you
want to learn a world model this is f
here F is the world model it takes in a
state and an action and it gives you the
next state or an approximation to it and
the parameters here indicate that this
is some sort of function that you learn
like a deep neural network you can do
this in fully or partially observed
environments now when you plan what you
want to do is you say I have a planning
horizon H right and I have a reward
function and the reward function is
gonna give me a reward for each state
action pair right so if I'm in a state
and I do a certain action I'm gonna get
some reward this could be you have
reached the target or this could be you
know how much money you've collected or
what not so we're going to look a
horizon age you're going to look H steps
into the future and you want to maximize
the sum of all the rewards here so in
the limit this reduces to simply like
for example reaching the target in our
rooms case if F H is infinite but you
can consider a lower planning
so you want to find the action sequence
that maximizes this reward in the future
okay and now this reward relies on your
environment model okay so here's the the
algorithm first you collect some data
okay that's how you start off then train
the dynamics model the world model using
the data you've already collected then
for each time step T you want to
optimize this trajectory so you want to
find the best next action sequence and
take the first action implement the
first action and get the new observation
and do you do this in a loop until the
end and at the end you say at this data
to D so that's what that's what you do
you use your world model to get the best
action sequence that's how you optimize
the trajectory and then at the end of
the episode you've you've done an
episode right you went somewhere you put
all of this into your training data to
make the world model better important to
note here is that the world model will
only learn about things that you have
done right so there is kind of an
interaction effect that's the green area
here the world model only knows the
paths the world model only can
accurately estimate the world where you
have been and that's going to turn out
to be the entire problem because the
this blue arrow finder can now go away
from there
from that that's explained here
potential inaccuracies of the trained
model caused substantial difficulties
for the planning process rather than
optimizing what really happens planning
can easily end up exploiting the
weaknesses of the predictive model
planning is effectively an adversarial
attack against the agents own forward
model this results in a wide gap between
expectations based on the model and what
actually happens okay and they have this
this example here where it's like an
indoor
real control process and what you have
to imagine there's like some sort of
container here with a liquid liquid in
it and there are two two pipes that lead
to this container pipe one and pipe 2
and there are valves here so there's
this valve right here and there's this
valve right here so these are valve 1
and valve 2 and there is also an output
pipe right here and that's a another
valve right here so you can control
these three valves the in two inputs and
one output and you have to somehow
optimize the reaction in here so this is
a chemical reaction made up out of the
two liquids that flow in here and you
have to somehow optimize a property of
that and that's highly nonlinear and has
maybe like time time shift so when you
open a valve it's going to take a while
and then it's very nonlinear and then
you are not supposed to break the
pressure limit so you have to also
outflow some stuff and if you just do
this with a learned model it looks like
this so first of all here is a classic
controller like people have been doing
this stuff in industry and they
basically build controllers for it and
you can you can do that and that works
out really ok ish as you can see right
here this is the product rate what
you're supposed to optimize and you see
some sort of a smooth you're supposed to
actually bring it to this dashed line
right here and and this is some sort of
smooth thing right and you're supposed
to I guess bring the pressure here and
the a in purge I don't know what these
quantities are but you're supposed to
bring them to the dashed line and it's
very nonlinear and very time-dependent
so that works and you see here kind of
the smoothness by which the variables
are manipulated now if you just learn a
world model and then do this trajectory
optimization basically basically this is
some sort of a yeah reinforced
reinforcement learning with a world
model
you see here it works but it's super
jittery the pressure spikes here and
apparently this here is a pressure limit
so it spikes the pressure limit and you
can see that the manipulated variables
are up and down and up and down and up
none because at each step it basically
completely overestimates it's it's
potentially rewarded things like wow
this is really good but all it does is
find a weakness in the model and not a
really good action per se now with their
method to already take it away you can
see that now the control task super
smoothly and very quickly converges to
these optimal things and you can see
that the variables being manipulated are
also rather smoothly manipulated and
that's an indication that the model is
accurately estimating their rewards okay
so how do they do it we are what they
call trajectory we are regularization of
trajectory optimization so in essence
what do we want to regularize here there
are many things we could do to solve
this but the way this paper goes is they
say we not only do we want the most
return we also want a high log
probability of our of our taken path so
this here as you can see this is
observation action and and so on
observation action so this is the future
this right here is the future so this
this sequence here is going is what is
going to give me the reward right here
right so G is also dependent on these
things but it's not said explicitly here
so G is dependent on your plan maybe
let's not call this the future this is
the plan okay this is the plan you came
up with so this is directly going to
influence G and G is the reward you're
going to get under your model but also
you want the log probability of the plan
itself to be high
now there I think there is a bit there
is something missing here and that is
conditioned on your training
distribution right here and I think
that's a actually rather crucial part no
that's that's the KL thing so this is
conditioned on your training so what you
want is you want the plan to be
basically in your training distribution
so you you want what you you want your
plan that you're going to execute if
that is actually part of your training
data set then you know I have already
executed this once before and it's
reasonable to assume that therefore my
world model has learned from this
experience and is going to give me an
accurate reward if we go back to our
rooms example then up here somewhere if
we go back to our rooms example right
you you see that anywhere in the green
area where I have already explored the
world model is fairly good right it's
going to give me accurate reflection of
the world but as soon as I go outside
the green area it is not and inside the
green area is basically where my
training data is now if I in the future
actually take a path here crashing to a
wall right here right the you saw in the
algorithm at the end of an episode I'm
going to add my trajectory to the
training data for the world model so
this green part here expands to include
that and now if I go here again if my
plan goes there again now I can trust
the world model but also now it has it
is actually correct because it has a
wall here so you see that the
regularization basically you not only do
I want the biggest reward possible under
my world model I also want that the plan
that I'm about to execute is has a high
probability under my training
distribution okay and the way we do this
is by denoising auto-encoders
so I want the log probability here to be
high and you do this via a denoising
auto-encoder what's a denoising
auto-encoder denoising auto-encoder is
basically so if you have for example an
image and the image is of a our trusty
cat whiskers and a denoising
auto-encoder is an unsupervised method
where you have it's basically an
autoencoder so there is a bunch of
layers compressing to a hidden
representation then uncompressing it
again okay and at the end you want to
output the same as at the beginning so
it's basically an auto encoder but the
special part about the denoising
auto-encoder is that first you take your
input and you know you put some noise on
it so that could mean it could mean
anything here but here what they do is
they do they've make some Gaussian noise
on it now I can't really draw Gaussian
noise here but it would be kind of
convolved with gaussian Gaussian noise
so I'm just going to add some noise like
this so noise noise noise so there are
some noise you see and then you feed
that that's now what you feed in here
and the algorithm is supposed to
reconstruct this this original image so
that the algorithm is basically supposed
to take away the noise it doesn't see
the original image but it's supposed to
produce it and you do this with your
training data so what does that mean
ultimately for our trajectory
optimization it means that if I have a
trajectory that I did before and it
maybe goes here right what I can do is I
can make a noisy version of it which
would be the black one right here so I
put some noise on it some noise right
it's it's kind of the same but okay and
the denoising auto-encoder is supposed
to give me back the red one
this will simply give me some sort of a
probabilistic model of my training
distribution so they go through the math
here and show that these denoising
auto-encoders actually naturally output
this log probability sorry the gradient
of the log probability because optimal
denoising theory says that for zero mean
and gaussian noise the optimal denoising
function the optimal the optimal
denoising function for zero mean
Gaussian corruption is this thing right
here so it is if if I if you give me X
and you tell me
X is has been corrupted by zero mean
Gaussian noise of size Sigma and then
the best and and you simply tell me give
me back the original image the best
thing I can do is to take what you gave
me and add this gradient of the log
probability of X if if I can if I have a
model of the log probability right so
that's the best thing I can do and
that's the best annoying function and
now you have to think a bit of in
Reverse if we train a denoising
auto-encoder that is going to
approximate this best function that
there is okay so we know that the best
possible denoising function is this we
train a denoising auto-encoder which in
the optimal case is going to converge to
the best denoising function so if we
then reformulate and we do denoising
auto-encoder
of x minus or x tilde minus x tilde that
is girl divided by this standard
deviation sorry the variance that is
going to give us this quantity right
here the gradient of the log probability
and the gradient of the log probability
of x is exactly
what we need to run gradient descent on
our function so here is our function
again G Plus this regularization now
they don't regularize over the entire
future but over these windows but in
essence it's g plus the log probability
of your plan if you take the gradient of
that of course it take the gradient of
the sum so it's the gradient of G plus
the gradient of the log probability with
respect to the actions and here simple
application of the chain rule will tell
you that you have to propagate through
the input through the X and you need
this quantity the gradient of the log
probability with respect to its inputs
now as we just saw the optimal denoising
auto-encoder is going to output that
problem that thing so if we train a
denoising auto-encoder
and we suppose its reach is a good
accuracy then we can obtain this
quantity basically for free and that's
the entire trick here so in essence what
does it mean
in essence what it means is that if we
are in our room again and we have our
partial model of the world let's say we
have this model because we are here and
all we've ever explored is so we've
explored this these things right here
okay and this now when I go and do my
trajectory optimization and my
trajectory optimization wants to go here
I simply say no I don't know that I
haven't seen that yet you can only plan
basically within the space where we have
already been so you can plan like here
so here now there there is of course
there is going to be some explorations
or some probability that you can go away
a bit but not too much right so in this
case it would result in the planning
only to happen in spaces where we've
actually been so it might go here and
then
here because okay here we haven't been
anywhere but then that would lead me to
take the first step in this direction
and not in this direction and if I take
my first step in this first direction
then of course I'm going to be already a
bit on the correct path right here
whereas I if I take the first step into
this direction then after that I'm gonna
have to if once I crash here I'm gonna
have to correct really hard and that's
exactly what's going to give you this
super jittery control whereas if you
only plan where you've already been you
won't the probability that you're going
to have to do like a 180 is going to be
much much lower okay that seems like
that's about it let's look at the
experiments so their experiments
basically actually want to go down here
to this in dust sorry need not the
industrial control process but to the MU
Joko experiments so these are kind of
continuous control tasks you might have
seen it so there's some like one is a a
the ant here is basically this 3d and
there's like a blob and it has I think
four legs and each leg has two joints
and it just needs to walk as far as
possible or reach some sort of goal and
the half cheetah is like a 2d thing
where I think it's something like this
it also has these two legs and it's
supposed to walk forward and not fall
over and you can put force basically on
each of the of the joints here so you
see that their baselines are Gaussian
processes and this pets thing is a
previous baseline to do to also do
model-based control with a learned model
and here they there's is the main their
main one is the red
one and as you can see that it goes much
faster well it basically outperforms the
rest in these high in these more
complicated tasks and then card pole or
something like this is is lower
dimensional easier tasks and you can see
that at least it does not hurt they make
they say here something they don't they
don't show in the plots they say that if
you let this run for a while then
basically the their method doesn't make
any improvement anymore whereas the
baseline methods will sort of at some
point surpass it and the reason that is
and I'm not sure if it's on this exact
task but they mention that which it's
it's respect so far is because they say
since we only plan where we know where
the droid since we only plan where we
know we basically do much less
exploration than others
we we can stick to what we know when we
plan so inherently we do less
exploration and doing our conversation
with Hari he basically said this this is
intended and the base the intention is
that you want to do your planning where
you know and then explicitly add the
component that does exploration so you
have control over so you can basically
say huh I I've never been here sort of
now you would be in an expression Phase
II would explicitly go there rather than
intermingle your you're planning with
your exploration and basically rely on
your planning to screw up and you're at
the exploring because if your plan if
your planning never screws up then you
won't explore either right then you will
always reach your goal or your planning
will always be correct and these other
methods that don't have this explicitly
they explore every time they're planning
screws up and you don't want that you
you're planning to be as good as
possible and they do that by sticking to
what they know and then they the next
step which is not in this paper would be
to add an explicit exploration policy to
reach areas they've never reached before
okay so that's the reason why they don't
ultimately reach the best accuracy but
they do reach a the initial accuracy
much faster than the other tasks because
they plan better they have a long
discussion here of bait what still
problems are like local minima or the
planning horizon problem open-loop
versus closed-loop compounding errors in
planning but I'm going to leave this out
for now and I thank you for being here I
very much invite you to check out the
paper for more details it's pretty cool
pretty easy to read actually it's very
written very well and with that see you
next time bye-bye